for many life in Yemen was already
difficult before the coronavirus now the
pandemic is making things even worse
over the last two months more than
20,000 families have turned to camps
like these in the Mara governor it their
homes are now makeshift tents health
care here is limited social distancing
impossible the UN says Yemen's health
care system has essentially collapsed we
hear from many of them that Yemen is
really on the brink right now the
situation is extremely alarming they are
talking about that the health system has
in effect collapsed they are talking
about having to turn people away because
they do not have enough oxygen they do
not have enough personal protective
equipment doctors are getting ready for
a rise in the number of patients but
they have little to offer them Yemen is
particularly vulnerable to the spread of
the virus poverty and water shortages
have left the war-torn country highly
susceptible to disease and money is
running out we are heading towards a
fiscal cliff if we do not get the money
coming in the programs that are keeping
people alive and are very much essential
to fight back against calm it will have
to close and then the world will have to
witness what happens in a country
without a functioning health system that
will cope with 98 agencies say
infections are likely underreported
because of scarce testing limited
resources and government secrecy and
calls to stop the fighting amid the
pandemic have been ignored leaving even
more people at risk were forced out of
the homes by armed men conflict violence
this is a dominant verdict on
international diplomacy on the raw
violence of armed groups but also of the
Security Council which has not in any
way supported the Secretary General's
call for a global coronavirus ceasefire
five years of war between allies of
Yemen's government and Hoodie forces
have destroyed or closed more than half
of the country's health
these people are now left facing a
disease that threatens to further
crippled our country already devastated
by war
Katia Lopez of the Y on al-jazeera